bonjour johann pitout j'ai 36 ans donc
je suis originaire de l'île de la
réunion et cela fait déjà deux ans que
je suis sur le territoire de la
métropole et que je travaille sur le sur
la suisse je suis commercial dans
téléphonie mobile et internet
donc je fais la vente de mobiles
de services à l'accès à internet j'ai
deux enfants de six ans et de trois mois
donc
ils ont pris l'habitude forcément des
parts un petit peu difficile mais avec
le temps les enfants s'habituent
je pense plus vite que nous les adultes
et puis bon ils se sont fait de nouveaux
quotas avec un nouvel environnement avec
l'école et tout ça se passe très bien
d'ailleurs on habite près des stations
de ski et mon fils y fait un post it la
natation c'est jeu très sympa j'ai
travaillé sur la métropole et puis avec
l'expérience je suis revenu ici pour
essayer de me revenir à l'île de la
réunion
et puis j'ai vu que c'était pas évident
et puis bon ben j'ai évolué à voir voir
autre chose et à partir de là j'ai pu
des marchés au niveau des entreprises
sur la suisse
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
les suisses ont très cordiaux ils sont
des gens très ouverts
j'ai les amis suisses avec les collègues
du travail également
donc forcément on entretient une
relation et puis bombers ont fait
découvrir aussi nos produits mais le
produit de la réunion justement qui ne
connaissent pas forcément
et puis bon on fait ça on se fait des
échanges ça se passe plutôt la femme a
travaillé en assurances maladie donc
c'est justement un domaine où il très
recherchés en suisse parce que la
population est très vieillissante alors
j'invite les réunionnais à découvrir ce
beau pays d'ailleurs donc tu es très
accueillants
avec énormément de posséder de travail
et donc le marché du travail qui est
vraiment qui est très bas au niveau du
chômage
les évolutions également vous avez
beaucoup davantage
et puis bon ben ce que je trouve bien
aussi bien au niveau salaire passe est
très intéressant et au niveau plan de
retraite c'est vraiment on est vraiment
se sent vraiment en sécurité à ce niveau
là c'est pas évident je dirais pas que
c'est trop facile non plus mais je dis
qu'il ya vraiment des possibilités et je
peux vous dire que moi je regrette pas
d'avoir fait le porte voix
je me présente à puis van peel tout donc
j'ai 36 ans je viens vous présenter un
petit peu donc mon expérience que j'ai
actuellement sur le territoire de la
suisse la suisse un pays qui a huit
millions d'habitants
sur les huit millions d'habitants il ya
39 % de l'étranger ce qui est énorme
pourquoi avoir choisi d'aller travailler
en suisse en suisse vous allez avoir
beaucoup d'argent mais à la fin du mois
les chansons cher par contre quand vous
êtes frontaliers vous allez avoir le
salaire de la suisse mais vous allez
habiter en france donc du coup ça vous
coûte beaucoup moins cher
pour ce qui concerne la candidature donc
comme toute entreprise
soyez ponctuels c'est très important ne
pas se faire remarquer arrivé en retard
gtrra prévoyez votre coup vous allez
faire votre démarche vous allez faire un
repérage dans un premier temps ça c'est
très important
attendez pas le jour j pour y arriver
c'est important de montrer que vous êtes
prêt à vous adapter en fonction de la
situation
ça c'est toujours important c'est ce
qu'ils recherchent
le salaire est en fonction de la du
diplôme de la formation vous avez de
l'expérience et de votre âge plus que
vous prenez de l'âge que vous êtes payé
faut pas se mettre une barrière se dire
ah mais moi j'ai pas le diplôme avec moi
j'ai pas les compétences non je vous
donne l'exemple coeur de mon cousin
il n'avait pas de diplôme ça a pas
empêchés de travailler si vous l'avez
dit vous avez toutes vos chances qu'on
est par contre il faut avoir la volonté
ces cieux que départ séparer la famille
y'a pas le soleil comme là bas ici
c'est sûr mais quand vous sortez vous
avez un bon salaire la fin du mois au
québec merci à tous d'être venus d'assez
de votre présence merci de m'avoir
écouté
j'espère que ça lui était agréable pour
vous en espérant que bas même si vous
partez pas tout de suite bien que vous
aurez peut-être la chance plus tard de
partir en tout cas c'est une expérience
à vivre et j'invite vraiment vous
rayonnez de partir parce que bon je
trouve dommage que la plupart ne savent
pas ne connaissent pas donc je remercie
encore le clan de m'avoir invité de
m'avoir laissé m'exprimer et j'espère
que ben premier d'entre vous d'un
quelqu'un trouvera sachant ça va ça ça
voudra vraiment la peine vous allez voir
vous mettrez pas de partir voilà alors
moi je me présente je m'appelle soin de
ménager vive j'ai 25 ans et je vous
cherchez un emploi en tant qu'éducatrice
spécialisé moi c'est monsieur albert et
franck je travaille déjà je fais en
ville entier je m'appelle quasimodo
quatre ans j'ai 26 ans je viens de la
peine
mais
actuellement
je recherche un emploi
de la logistique la mobilité pour moi
c'est la découvrir découverte d'autres
choses de notre culture c'est vrai que
c'est une approche intéressante et je
pense vraiment élargir mon
monchamp au début de la recherche ont
pas comme ici c'est un peu
fermez j'irai donc j'ai eu l'idée de
partir l'humilité et d'essayer de matons
ma chance je suis pas sage fait campagne
et je prends aussi avec mon compagnon
également
donc je pense que c'est vraiment aussi
un plus justement en termes de soutien
si je pars en famille avec mes enfants
ma femme tout ça c'est surtout pour
pouvoir faire des économies
parce qu'ici c'est dur j'aimerais
pouvoir leur donner la chance aussi de
deux glissières de pouvoir revivre la
même chose que moi là bas elle fait
d'avoir entendu monsieur pitot alors
déjà nous part j'ai trouvé les
échanges très enrichissants et assez
pertinents franchement ça donne envie
d'y aller quoi d'essayer un peu de fond
c'est pour tenter sa chance
ça donne envie de partir en vue
d'essayer maintenant je dirais qu'il
faut franchir le cap
se lancer du super motivé par rapport
par rapport à mon départ l'aide à la
mobilité
j'ai très envie de partir ça a toujours
été un désir depuis de trop longues
dates découvrir autre chose et c'est
d'avancer dans la vie d'une autre façon
en france dans lacunes celui vous
conseille qu'est ce qui pourrait vous
empêcher de partir rien c'est décidé je
parle contactez nous sur notre page
facebook www.facebook.com slash 9 7 4 tv
ou par téléphone 02 100 62 92 37 60
de 7 4 cv autre émission au service de
l'emploi à la réunion